right now as we speak
we are on twitch i don't know what it is
i don't know how it works
but we're there so if you're on twitch
you just find me at the tony michaels
just like anywhere else tick tock
youtube
the tweet machine and we're on there
so i'll put some links up after today
after i figure out what the hell twitch
is
at d tonymichaels.com i did open up a
twitch account uh
a while back because you know you gotta
capture the screen name
but um i don't know what twitch is
so we'll find out we'll keep going with
twitch too as long as people
watch it there i guess i have no idea i
don't know
i don't know if there's uh i don't know
if it's uh
if it's a thing where where uh you get
to replay your videos i think it replays
the videos and let you replay the videos
but
i don't know we'll figure that [ __ ] out
we'll put the links up somewhere
some [ __ ] you know how it goes
but it's wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern like every
goddamn week i'm right here yelling and
screaming into the microphone